so you've been playing a lot of Fire
Emblem three houses maybe you're still
on your first playthrough maybe you're
starting a new game+ or maybe you're
already best friends with all three
house leaders no matter what if you're a
bit further into the game and looking
for some in-depth tips we've got you
covered there are some minor spoilers
ahead so if you orange at least a few
months in yet check out our other tips
videos first
depending on which house you picked
there are certain people you might want
to recruit or not pay attention to if
you're in the Black Eagles and we'll
follow edelgard to the ends of the earth
don't bother with flame setteth
Catherine or Cyril anyhow can benefit
from Felix who is just really really
strong birthday as meteor and Maryanne
silence ability are both very useful to
and Ash's permanent lockpick ability
comes in handy if you don't have any
thieves or assassins on your team
finally Ingrid is one of the few
students built to be a Pegasus Knight
and she's also a delight to have around
protip if you reach B support with
someone outside your class recruiting
them is a breeze
in months 12 you'll have the opportunity
to enter one of your students in the
White Heron Cup where they can unlock
the exclusive dancer class dancers can
be clutch support units they can dance
for an adjacent unit to give them a
second turn and are good with Sword
Authority and magic strong options are
Dorothea Lysa Thea and Mary Anne for
their skill strengths or flame if you're
not in the Black Eagles since she's all
support already keep in mind that your
dancer needs at least 13 charm to win
and you can tutor them in dancing ahead
of time using an activity point to
increase their term by five raising
support levels with your students as
well as other students and faculty is
one of the most important aspects of
three houses not only do characters
become more effective on the battlefield
but you can also learn more about their
backstory and personality but don't try
too hard to max out support levels right
away you won't be able to reach a
support with anyone or between anyone
else until after the time-skip happens
in New Game+ you can spend renowned to
unlock things like skill levels support
levels and professor level you can also
unlock class abilities with renown and
this is something you should pay
attention to you before you start a new
game plus when a unit reaches class
mastery with a certain class by battling
a bunch you'll get a special ability to
equip if you have that same unit in your
party in a new game plus save you can
skip the time you'd spend leveling up
that class and get the ability right
away some of the class abilities are
pretty useful so taking the time to make
sure your favorite units are reaching
class mastery in their best classes will
be super helpful in later playthroughs
try your best to break all four yellow
squares under a monster before killing
it this will stun it for a full turn and
you'll get a piece of rare or that's
important in forging powerful weapons
from breasted ones for example breaking
a big birds shields will get you my
thrill a material needed to forge rare
named weapons you might find on the
battlefield combat arts like an axe
users monster breaker or a lance users
monster piercer can break a portion of
the shield in one hit and gambits are a
good way to damage multiple squares at
once you might be wondering what exactly
it takes for a unit to attack twice it
all has to do with the speed stat if a
unit speed is four or more points
greater than your opponent's you'll
automatically attack twice in one go and
depending on the weapon you might even
be able to attack four times in one
combat encounter
there are quite a few weapons to choose
from in Fire Emblem and some are
designed to deal with specific units the
Arbor Slayer is a slore designed to
dispatch armored units the horse Slayer
Lance is good against you guessed it
cavalry units the mace works wonders on
armored units and the mini bow can be
used at close range
almost every weapon type also has brave
and killer variations the brave weapons
allowed the user to attack twice or
maybe more if their speed is high enough
and the killer weapons have an increased
critical hit rate I find that these
specialized weapons are a good backup
weapon to complement your standard sword
or axe
for some reason enemies love to
prioritize your lower defense units such
as archers and mages the obvious
solution and often the best one is to
leave with your tanker units and keep
your weaker ranged units behind you
however high mobility units like Pegasus
Knights can still cut through your units
and flank your more vulnerable students
in these situations you should be
constantly checking your enemy's range
with Zr but I also recommend equipping
your weaker units with Auto healing
items such as the prayer ring or goddess
ring and trying to increase their
defense and resistance stats with
permanent stat boost items like the
fruit of life if one of your students is
underleveled and you're afraid to bring
them into battle directly you could also
attach them to other units as adjudant
this means they can earn XP while
staying safe it's pretty easy to
overlook as the game never really tells
you about it but there's a character
called online liaison that connects you
with travelers online through these
online travelers you can buy items for a
discounted price do recon training which
is essentially a hide-and-seek game that
Nets you resources as a reward and hire
them as a juden sind battle with the
potential of them teaching you an
ability or combat art that they might
have you can also send one of your units
out into the net to reap the rewards
like gold and items those units can
still be used in battle even when
they're sent off to travel the online
liaison is hanging out near the officers
academy but know that you need a
Nintendo switch online subscription to
use online features that about covers it
for this round of tips let us know what
other more in-depth tips you have for
Fire Emblem 3 houses in the comments and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]